hey guys in this mkbhd video we're going
to be taking an unbiased look at
technology in 2010 a year in review
and yes a lot good and bad happened this
year but let's take a look more of the
pros and the cons shall we i can hardly
talk about tech this year without
talking about the ipad which was
launched by apple computers in 2010
early followed by a ton of other tablets
trying to capitalize on this
revolutionary new market these tablets
included samsung toshiba sharp rim asus
nec and a lot more
in 2010 apple also released their iphone
4 which featured a new retina display
and ios 4. this is one of their killer
products this year and probably one of
their best selling of all time it's one
of the thinnest fastest phones on the
market and also one of the first to have
a front-facing video camera to really
integrate video chat so good work apple
apple's iphone seem to take a big lead
in the super phone era where a whole
bunch of phones were released afterwards
that really took an aim at its throne
microsoft's windows phone 7 platform was
hoping to be more successful than the
kin 1 and kin 2 which were actually
pulled after 2 months of crappy sales
and also android by google was released
and has made major strides this year
the nexus one was the first pure google
phone to run android 2.2 and really
offer a pretty awesome experience for
google users and this was followed
pretty quickly by other android 2.2
phones that took advantage of a one
gigahertz processor
android also pulled some impressive
numbers and passed ios as the most
popular mobile operating system in the
united states
the latest iteration of android
available in 2010 was 2.3 gingerbread
available only on the nexus s the best
android phones of the year i'd say the
samsung galaxy s the droid x and that
nexus one and nexus s good work google
next up on our list is the social
networking explosion of 2010 which
included massive growth of twitter
probably the most popular social network
and you can follow me at mkbhd and also
the milestone of 500 million users using
facebook around the world those aren't
the only social networks so google buzz
made its debut integrating with users
gmail accounts yeah for people who
already have facebook and twitter
however it seemed like just another
social network now you may have noticed
at the beginning of the year at ces 2010
2010 really pushed 3d technology in tvs
but it's still pretty much a novelty
because of the lack of content and the
cumbersome glasses google tv also
emerged and combines web and video but
is still really ahead of its time
hopefully this will be big in 2011. i
like it and speaking of web video
youtube is still the number one video
platform in 2010 sweet
not a gaming the xbox 360 slim and the
connect look to revolutionize gaming and
the playstation 3 and playstation move
also joined the party to take down
nintendo in motion controlled gaming i
don't really have a preference yet but
you might
later in this year apple also released
their finally long awaited macbook air
refresh and you'll notice something it
just keeps getting thinner and thinner
trying to imagine the 2020 macbook air
holy crap
it's not really the specs of that
notebook that are really impressive it's
the form factor and that's what apple
does best
and onto google cr-48 the netbook's
hardware isn't anything special but yes
chrome os is revolutionary so google
keeps getting better and better i hope
to become part of the pilot program so i
can test one of these bad boys
overall no matter which way you look at
it google and apple really dominated the
tech scene in 2010. this year the mkbhd
channel also saw more than 250 new
uploads with a combination of hardware
and software and tutorials i'd say 2011
has a tough act to follow either way
this has been mkbhd with a look at
technology in 2010 happy new year and i
will see you guys in 2011
peace